the Finish are the happiest people in
the world happier than the United States
of America New York Times it has been
ranked the happiest Nation on Earth but
in this article they talked to the
individual Finns Public Funding for
education in the Arts including
individual artist grants gives people
like his wife Herta a mixed media artist
the freedom to pursue their creative
passions it also affects the kind of
work that we make because we don't have
to think of the commercial value of art
I mean can we get some or hurt to is
there anything that we can see here from
Herta
the The Finnish mixed media artist
because I want to be proven wrong now go
up there what is this with the two what
is that two eggs this is what you do
when you don't have to think of the
commercial value of art the government
pays for this to put scrunchies on
a metal pipe and call it art and that's
what they pay for you know what I think
would make her better working a Taco
Bell for minimum wage